[Music]
i
what's wrong with little quarter black
he had a rough day at school
he said none of the kids would talk to
him
i have an idea
oh boy suge knight ruxpin i swear to
y'all this like this i'm gonna beat the
dogs out of you
if i'm telling you since the police
didn't do it they're punk ass
see if i asked me if i knew who killed
tupac i'm gonna say hey
absolutely not
[Music]
i'm gonna take you up
good night suge knight ruxpin
you'll be my best friend forever
cause we're all gonna die
nobody's gonna leave here live and
people die all the time suge knight
ruxpin batteries and dr dre's masters
sold separately
[Music]
dot com
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
stranger
[Music]
[Music]
hmm
that's the sound of being back with you
yeah today hope you enjoyed yesterday's
infiltration of fat studies that's an
actual program and
major at our higher institutions and uh
hey look now now i'm peer-reviewed oh
nice and i'll be reviewing other uh
peers
this is a terrible world that's one
thing that we haven't told you i i have
been
repeatedly
asked by other
rotund professors to review their
research
and provide notes no it's not a real
thing it was it was a goof so
uh i will probably have some more uh
coming on that soon we'll have some
other change my minds on the topic but
uh boy it is uh it's a lovely day uh a
lot going on here in the news and look
really quickly before i move on with
anything else if this show is not on
youtube if we do not tell you that we
are not doing a show it means the show
is going on all well all weekdays monday
through thursday
10 a.m eastern monday through thursday
you can watch it on rumble if it's not
here on youtube or of course mug club
where we will be doing an additional
like hour of show every day live
earthquaker.com mug club it's the only
way
we earn a living uh and you can also buy
a sugar network
really crowder shop you can't
no you cannot but my question to you is
okay first question
did you ever really doubt the hunter
biden laptop story
should be a shortage you know what and
since i know that's a yes or no i want
you to answer with degrees of certainty
give me a scale from one being least
certain to 10 being
how everybody actually felt how many
were there
but we'll get into that too smartest man
former vice president biden knows so uh
we talk about that and also the refugee
crisis here today this is something
you've been hearing a lot in the media
that hey we're treating ukrainian
refugees differently because they're
white it's the exact opposite we bring
in far more non-white refugees that's
been happening for years and by the way
the united states has not put in that
many ukrainian refugees just to be clear
so don't let them browbeat you into
being afraid of being accused of being a
racist because they're going to do it
anyway but you know this gerald a is
here how are you sir i am well sir you
looked fantastic as a woman yesterday if
i if i do say i wasn't going for
fantastic i was going for fat unkempt
and peer-reviewed fantastic i'm sorry
well
how are you doing
uh well you know i'm gonna take a while
to earn back self-respect degrees of
self-respect just stay there for a
minute you guys can rate how much
self-respect do you think i have degrees
one being well zero to ten
i think i think i fall somewhere in a
four oh okay all right yeah you and i
mean so by tomorrow like a three right
yeah okay cool yeah which means like in
the realm of stand-up in the realm of
comedian i'm like a seven well that's
true in the realm of normal people four
i'm probably a four speaking of uh
brilliant comedians fastest man on his
feet you know me you can find him on
twitter at landau dave dave landau ahoy
how are you good you grow a beard fast i
do
i do grow it's like a day yeah
he's like a chia pet just that water
impressive well the actual seminar we've
been sitting on for a very long time oh
because we wanted to see what else they
did but it turns out they don't do much
the fets that studies professors no it's
very slow
it's almost like movie magic yes
it's almost like a reptile exhibit you
know you put a heat lamp on them
[Laughter]
it's they're sedentary physically and
mentally which we'll get to in in a
couple minutes
when i'm no when you were there how
would you describe
until they invent smell-o-vision
yeah the schnaazberry smell like
schnaazberries the fat pride activists
smell like cheese
probably accurate bacterial yeast
cultures you can you can use them to
make kefir no no no that's disgusting it
doesn't exist in a microcosm just like
we'll be talking about lawyers these
scenarios right now we're talking about
a supreme court justice these people
right now who are today's fat studies
professors
the students are going to be building
your planes the students are going to be
teaching your children today when you
have lawyers like at georgetown right
who are upset over the supreme court now
actually i should say upset over the
fact that their professor did not
support the supreme court nominee solely
based
on the uh you know the premise of race
they needed a place to go and cry these
are the people who are going to be on
your future supreme courts these are the
people who are going to be your public
defenders think about that for a second
and it is terrifying
imagine a world imagine a world where
kids who are going to these colleges are
building your roads building your planes
and then when one goes down and there's
a lawsuit no one can handle anything
they need a safe place to need a safe
place
a safe place to mourn a survivor so did
i like something that wasn't going to
crash imagine if pilot school was like
this for sully yeah you would still be
pulling bodies out of the hudson oh by
far
all right there'd only be eight people
allowed on the plane right
well that's also the fat studies yeah
well yeah true let's see i always get
the first class ticket
tax man takes a share doesn't he okay so
before we move on to any of that there's
uh look nancy pelosi is um i always
thought that nancy pelosi was relatively
sharp i used to say this
two people have ever referred to as evil
two people have ever referred to as evil
nancy pelosi and governor whitmer
those are the only two people who have
said i i i genuinely think they would
you know they would shop off they would
chop up their spouse's uh body to sell
the body parts of china for medical
experiments i don't just think they're
politicians i think they're people with
a lack of empathy complete that being
said i thought that nancy pelosi was
relatively sharp i thought you meant
like sharp like bony that too yeah sure
she throws away pointy
no nine to fives now nancy pelosi it's
not allowed under unified rules but
i was wrong
she is now completely incr incron now
i'm
incomprehensible
this just surfaced but here's from a
press conference uh just a couple of
weeks ago
we're sending stuff over to the senate
well it's
most of the product that we've done is
except now
we may have added in the last day or so
and some of what we added is senate
to the bill like a hearing
bernie doesn't like hearing
that bernie loves hearing he would love
to hear
what he can
somebody sent orient and then we had the
family medical need we figured if
they're putting things in then we can
put something
even if manchin doesn't like it so um
uh
so we are getting some
bird and privilege
i think i think mostly we're getting
privileged scrub
because privilege strike is definitely
to a bill vertical
is important is you have to take it out
but
privilege violation can take you out
so bird
bones
scrub
follow up
what
[Laughter]
i'm usually able to make you it makes
sense like that's a word right
no clearly she had chloroform for
breakfast
[Laughter]
she chloroforms herself like michael
caiden the cider house rules she just
said ladies and gentlemen that's the
speaker of the house yes the speaker of
the house that was when you mix cocaine
and ghb yes only to be outdone by the
sitting former vice president
speaker it's in the name all you're
really supposed to do is speak and you
don't even have to be
you know mrs eloquent you just have to
not be functionally [ __ ] right yeah
no mad libs are way more coherent than
anything she just said but do you
remember when ron paul had a stroke live
on a live stream we're all concerned he
made more sense in the stroke moment for
crying out loud frankie muniz when he
had his 19 mini strokes in his nascar i
was still talking to the helmet like
nothing happened
can we get mini stroke
munez yes yes to be speaker of the house
is there a bird senate
you know what i wanted to see i want to
see somebody signing that i know
somebody had to be there to sign i want
to see this
just going
like what the [ __ ]
just robert byrd's corpse you rang
n don't say the word robert bird you
already said it many many times you get
it you're in the clan you love the n
word just stop
so bad did anyone understand this no no
huh
person who comments below and gives the
most accurate accurate translation of
that will win a lock of gerald's hair
we can't keep giving that away
body hair
well there's plenty of that there's a
lot yeah there's a lot
really gross we're crying out loud i
mean ugh yeah it's like your friends
here it's like you're wearing like
you're wearing wool [ __ ] traps
um
i love about sam elliott he was so upset
like you've got one homoerotic gentleman
and
leather chaps one in wooly [ __ ] chaps
like he really hates the woolly chest he
really does they have to be functional
he doesn't want him so nearly chaps are
a little much that don't really make
much sense speaking of not making sense
this this is when it's bad is you want
to go in and defend your own right
americans he was like we can make fun of
her but you don't want the rest of the
world to make fun of it's like
protecting your little brother but even
australian
news commentators this is sky news by
the way which isn't necessarily a
bastion of conservatism i know they're
leaning a little more right now not when
i used to do it uh
this is the rest of the world is
laughing at you look what they said
about the previous administration they
said that trump was horrible and then he
was crazy and then he was racist and
that he was a terrible leader and he
said all of these awful things and they
peddled just complete fake news and fake
stories about him they promised that
they would do better and they would be
the adult in the room and everything
would be just normal and lovely when
they got into power and now they've got
into power and rather than improving on
trump you've got a president who is
completely off with the pixies you've
got a vice president who the very best
thing about her is that she can do a bad
french accent and given that clip of
nancy pelosi you have a speaker of the
house who apparently doesn't know her
arthur from her martha
[Music]
i like the whole 50s look that she has
going on i do i was wondering sort of
rockabilly but without all the tattoos
and meth yeah it's true yeah i i do i
think it's a good look i think it's a
good look and i didn't really hear what
she was saying but i assume it was
pretty bad by the way if you hear me
saying no it's because joe lewis is in
the studio and he's not supposed to be
chewing his paw right now and he's
chewing it so it's because i was licking
myself yes
well so was gerald he was getting ready
for the body shaver because one of you
is going to be getting his luscious
locks
not at all it's not happening he uses
argon oil on it no no no
he does candle wax and then rips it off
okay we'll move on to this because we're
going to be talking about media
corruption here with the biden laptop
story and ukrainian refugee issue it's
just look if you want to know public
enemy number one it really it's not only
traditional media it's traditional media
and of course uh big tech and uh they
are one and the same now because of the
advertising dollars and unfortunately
now they're in an unholy relationship
with the lady you just saw not
attractive 50s australian i mean nancy
pelosi and the white house so babylon b
for people who don't you know they're
a satire website yeah like a
right-leaning onion uh and funnier onion
used to be great onion pretty tough now
yeah to read but uh they were suspended
from twitter
a satire site really and here's what's
so confusing about this because it's not
really satire but it technically is
satire and
either wherever you line up on this
either way according to twitter it's
hate speech so their tweet read the
babylon the babylon bees man of the year
is rachel levine
[Laughter]
and that violated twitter's hateful
conduct oh
rule which is look usa this is the one
thing too we all know these titles don't
usa today's you know their women of the
year used to be a figurative dick
measuring contest and now it is a
literal dick measuring contest it is
[Laughter]
i'm just glad that uh white men are
getting all of women's awards yes yes
because white men have been sweating
hard for too long and swimming titles i
think it's important that leah thomas
swam her balls off it's important and it
takes balls to be the woman of the year
guys i am surprised that that dick
didn't slow her down well you know
there's shrinkage in those pools
it
doesn't
[Music]
time to be a champion i would watch you
laugh i don't watch your lap and you can
by the way the thing is to win leo
thomas
yeah it's easy when you don't have
breasts yes when leah thomas yeah the
crisp they're buoyant they're buoyant
devices yeah it's like the seat cushion
on an airplane only you know more fun
the thing is with uh leah thomas the
coach i don't know that you could the
coach was yelling you know they always
they encourage you the coach was yelling
slow down
[Music]
because in the preliminaries just laps
them like we know that this guy
man by the way i'm not saying male
female and that's another thing people
talk about the the term sex versus
gender yeah rachel levine was referred
to as female four-star admiral by this
administration right female is a
biological term look it's not about
gender versus sex i've always been
telling you that gender was a
grammatical term they just wanted to
just get their foot in the door and now
guess what well look if it's about
gender versus sex okay so you're gender
social right sociological okay you
identify as a woman right
but sports are separated by biology
so
so even if you want to argue women of
the women of the year with usa today you
can't argue the ncaa swimming titles my
point is they're just going to keep on
going down the trail to the point where
you can't forbid your six-year-old son
from puberty blockers uh unless they
take your child away from you it was
never about taking a dump in a target
with a fake mustache so really if chris
brown had just put a bow in his hair
he'd just be an excellent exactly
he just needed the minnie mouse dress
everybody would have been clapping his
for his bravery yes yes
what did she say to you yeah
set you off like that exactly bam
rihanna well she wouldn't stop wouldn't
stop complaining about the umbrellas
yeah where was it
where's it i get it i get it i get it
i'll find it
[Music]
start swinging give me a minute you
blame him yeah i can't believe him i
thought my alarm clock was broken when
that was playing
[Music]
what time were we removed
all right
does it work on tick tock apparently it
does on youtube well now let's move on
oh i feel like like price is right like
we go from the bahamas to the maldives
so right now let's move on down to uh or
what where was well we'll move up to
georgetown university so uh you guys
know the senate uh uh confirmation
hearings for biden's supreme court pick
uh i want to make sure i get this name
right ken tanji brown jackson they began
yesterday yeah so everyone's been
talking about that
and this is really important because of
uh you know clarence thomas is is in the
hospital right now yeah and i i just and
they say he's going to be out in two
like two days i just hope it's not we
swap a black person for another black
like the fresh prince mom
yes and they just hope that we don't
notice that was really weird yes you're
like she's not even the same color no
it's not
even close she wasn't like they wouldn't
if they went into you know sephora they
wouldn't be in the same aisle i never
saw oh
fresh prince they changed the mob what
about that yeah because you're cutting
because he's colorful notice that a dark
black woman went to a very light-skinned
woman who looked nothing like the other
woman yeah i uh i never watched the show
that often until later and i never saw i
just now i'm having that revelation just
to be clear i don't mean this in the
figurative sense gerald is actually kind
of yeah partially yeah that's true well
i guess that's why he doesn't see shades
of slack yeah
yeah i don't think there's a human on
the planet that's black colorblind
so this is a big guy he totally does not
understand racism he's like no i really
don't get it i don't understand
everybody's white to me it's weird
it's like the pirates where they give
them the black dot like the black you've
been marked what's what is this i don't
know like it's the black dot it's just a
sheet of paper
it's your mark for death it's the black
dot it's just a sheet there's no dot
everything is just clear yeah
all right give me a red dot
can't see that it's just kilau i'm red
green we don't need all the theatrics
so uh the supreme court hearings are
starting but uh last month uh georgetown
this is a story that happened last month
georgetown professor ilya shapiro
was a put on administrative leave
specifically for criticizing bidens now
to be clear saying that biden shouldn't
be picking former vice president biden
shouldn't be picking a supreme court
nominee right based on race and
sex i don't know about sex or gender i
think sex whatever ish yes please so sex
gender
race so this professor at georgetown
right highly pers it's a very
prestigious school i don't know but law
school great law school i mean they all
have the same textbooks
i mean it just you know you clerk
because you have your name next to a
school on your degree i don't know how
much better these schools are than other
schools
it's good enough i know a guy from
harvard law who's the dumbest human
being i've ever met in my life then i
know someone who's brilliant yeah yeah
so um admit this this professor
georgetown put on administrative leave
for criticizing biden making that a
priority the racial preference with the
nominee and then specifically some of
the students were really upset about
some tweets let me read you the tweets
this is from the professor uh sri
was it sri sriniv
okay i'm gonna make sure i get this name
he wrote objectively best pick for biden
is sri srinivasan
sri srinivasan i think is that the term
he said but alas doesn't fit into the
latest intersectionality hierarchy so
we'll get lesser black women
then he also wrote because biden said
he's only considering black women for
supreme court his nominee will always
have an asterisk attached fitting that
the court takes up affirmative action
next
term wow
now at the very end of that first quote
we'll always get a lesser or we'll get a
lesser like i mean his point is true
that's the lesser candidate right but it
sounds i can see how it sounds a little
bad well here's the thing the students
lost their minds well it's not lost your
mind territory it's just like they lost
their minds and by the way he's right
about always having asterisk next yeah
if you go back to change my mind that i
did at ut austin and i said that
affirmative action is racist this one
girl it's one of the most heartbreaking
changes i've ever done
she sat down and she was she was uh
black um and she said uh well you know
uh for me i think that i i needed it you
know what about people like me and i
said well what about a person like you
she said well you know i'm here at ut
and i said and you don't think you would
have made it here to ut austin you don't
think you would have made it in if not
for affirmative action she said well i
don't know i said what were your grades
like and she was you know top of her
class yeah i said what were your
extracurriculars like and she had a ton
of extracurriculars she wrote a great
paper yeah i said seems to what are your
grades like here at ut and she was you
know straight a student
i said
this is really sad so i said i look at
you and i hear what you're telling me
and i think that you're perfect student
i think you should be able to punch your
tick and go to any university you want
to and i don't think that it should have
anything to do with your race
it's sad to me do you think you
do you think that the only reason you're
here at ut is because of your race
and she said i'd like to think not i
said well i'm telling you it's not yeah
and that's my problem with affirmative
action and then she agreed that was sad
to me you robbed someone of that feeling
of self
of accomplishment so a student then
partaking in a sit-in they actually
asked the administration for a place to
go and cry now i know here's the thing
you're used to hearing this from like
gender studies students right or
feminists because we expect them all to
be weak these are your future lawyers
judges clerks there's no crying in laws
there's no crying in law school come on
come on guys so
they asked is there an office that they
could go to they said i don't know what
it would look like but if they want to
cry if they need to break down where can
they go because we're at a point where
students are coming out of class to go
to the bathroom
to cry
what law students have to leave brian in
the boar's room yes yes
by the way i don't know if you know this
professor shapiro suggested another
another female minority yes i that wait
i'm sorry are you saying that name was
uh suggested another yeah
whatever the hell it is i can't even
pronounce it it wasn't like a white
anglo-saxon i can't write sins i can't
read sang script i mean why why is there
preference for a black woman to be the
next supreme court this is a totally
legitimate
not only grievance but a discussion for
a professor to have hey look do we
really want to be picking so it went
from this is why i say it's not about
gender versus sex in this case
affirmative action wasn't about giving
people a fair shake to correct uh
historical injustices where does it go
well we have affirmative action and now
it's wait hold on a second we don't even
want a professor to be able to say that
a judge to the highest court in the land
should not be picked should not be
picked exclusively based on race and
gender that is not even an opinion
that's allowed we need a room to go cry
and break down these are going to be the
people running your country yes to the
future court appointed attorneys yes
[Laughter]
crying in the bathroom how are you gonna
do anything
anything in life at all yeah i mean pay
a bill anything at all in life if you
have to cry during here if you hear
something you don't like well this is
the way this is what universities have
become is just eliminate voices you
don't like don't send your kids to
school ever well in safe spaces i was at
notre dame i was in one of the common
areas and there was a room that said
safe space for students of color and i
was like why when at notre dame had
notre dame when you went there no no
when i went back
notre dame there's probably like four
people in that room yeah i was going to
see where you'd go to buy drugs that was
actually threesomes an irish guy right
yeah
that's the one italian yes
i mean i i just i don't like them and
i don't understand the concept of
running to your group to be able to say
what you need to say i thought the whole
purpose was to have conversations with
other people that's what diversity does
is it gives you perspective and if you
only go and have perspective with people
like you you get rid of diversity well
here's the thing now it's not only about
eliminating diversity among the student
body but also the professor of course
which is why you see some schools where
some schools have not one conservative
professor you can go back through all
references available at credit.com by
the way you can go back through some
previous show maps it is unbelievable
nowhere else in the population do you
see this imbalance of left versus right
you see it in hollywood you see it in
media and you see it in uh in education
that's about it it really should be hard
for a man to cry i'm sorry yes like it
just is a natural thing i'm not like
it's not really like they act like it's
beat into you it's not no it's not you
you know you have to bury your bulldog
you cry you lose a relative you cry you
get kicked in the nuts for the first
time maybe you cry you cry later though
like when you lose like your dad it's
five years later and you're watching
home improvement i know from experience
yes exactly it's just like it's you it's
not that easy you shouldn't just bawl
your eyes out because you heard
something you didn't like no it doesn't
make any sense zero sense no and this is
the thing they say it's toxic
masculinity right that's being
conditioned into you that's not true
it's not true this is an active form of
conditioning where they want to tell
young men do you want to cry cry do you
need a room we'll give you a room to cry
you should cry it's it's actually it's
actually not a great thing to cry
there's nothing wrong with men crying
when appropriate right but encouraging
men to cry where they wouldn't otherwise
cry and it's incredibly inappropriate is
definitely not good for our society well
listen brendan frazier in bedazzled
wouldn't cry at that tweet
does anybody get the reference you guys
i do get the reference but i'm just sad
that you brought it out
i i did i did have
i did have
show time when i was kid and i was
too hungover to find the remote yeah you
want to reference uh you want to
reference constantine next yes
charlie sheen yeah you guys got some
good jake speed references for us
hudson hawk on your schedule for today
actually that was pretty good
that is a movie i watched too many times
why did they play that on a loop yeah
well you played it on a loop well
they're too high to hit stop that's like
hbo well yeah hbo2 came out and they
were like i think we can just do hudson
hawk for a while yes
that's where the pallet
this really is though it's a terrifying
time to be alive in this country to know
to know
that we are going into unprecedented
territory everyone ah these kids that's
not music you know because the beatles
said they wanted to hold your hand okay
i get it all right fine this is a little
bit different though when we are talking
about a new generation of people who
don't believe that men and women are a
thing
who don't believe that there are
differences between men and women who
don't believe that there's an
appropriate time who've actually been
taught that the idea of pulling yourself
up by your bootstraps is an archaic
ideology it's one that's actually
insulting it's toxic masculinity that
they should be able to elimin they
shouldn't have to live their life
hearing any opinions with which they
disagree and these are the people who
are also by the way being proclaimed
intellectuals because they happen to be
the only ones able to tolerate pardon me
the [ __ ] in higher education you're
going to see a divide where intelligent
people people with common sense people
with likely higher iqs are not are not
going to want to go to ivy league
universities they're not going to want
to go to public universities they're not
going to want to have to deal with it
yeah
and that's why they want to make a
college degree the new high school
degree where everyone has to have one to
be employed you shouldn't need it you
should be good at your job i really just
want us to go to performance
performance-based pay across the board
that's the only way we pull ourselves
out of this rut is the market slaps some
reality into these kids because if you
show up as some gender-bending
blue-haired feminist who doesn't like to
hear that your boss says that's not the
way you clean the cappuccino machine
they're going to drown you in it they
should pretty much right yeah or back to
like you know white people right well
you know in the emerging markets right
now you know countries that are
up nobody gets to say that you have to
work hard we just have had so much
success you're living off of the success
of your parents right now that's it and
it won't last very long until we have a
real problem in this case i think people
are living off the mediocrity of a lot
of their parents well it's probably it's
really the greatest generation it's your
parents parents right now we're or the
welfare getting off of that success
everyone sucks yeah well hey i had a
better attitude but i'm just
black-pilled it's okay
i can't see that by the way stop taking
the pills in my desk uh it's not what
you think they are
enjoy the pretty colors hey
livewithcrowder.com tour
you can go to we're adding shows all the
time me and dave we're going to be in
tulsa oklahoma there are some seats left
may 14th tulsa oklahoma may 14th and
june 18th we add another show at pikes
peak or sorry colorado springs colorado
it's at the pikes peak center but it's
in colorado springs june 18th we had to
add a whole new show so there are
tickets there uh and uh just check lot
of credit.com tour because we're adding
dates all the time and we don't mention
all them on the show and uh you won't
have any brendan fraser jokes we will
not have you seen him lately yeah well
he was in that show where i assume
that's why he had to gain weight because
he looked like brendan frick he looked
like a balloon of brendan he looks like
rodney dangerfield yeah a little bit can
i you should play rodney dangerfield
give me a favorite guess guess one
reason why a teenager would watch that
movie what movie oh come on we all know
bedazzled we all know the answer that's
because brendan fraser's dimples are
just i can get lost in them yes that is
true i could go swimming in those
dimples you guys are giving me crap for
watching a movie where basically it's a
little early it looks beautiful in any
outfit they put her in because she's
constantly changing into different
characters of course i'd watch that
movie i i'm not saying you should i'm
just saying that's why i didn't know
what you're saying
is you hope the devil looks like
elizabeth hurley because you've sinned
and you're going to meet him well that's
actually probably how the devil is going
to show up it's not going to be a great
freaky coffin it's going to be a
secretary who looks like elizabeth
hurley well then hail satan yeah
jeez
you don't need to go see elizabeth
hurley movies anymore she has an
instagram for crying out loud oh that's
true yeah you don't have to sit through
be dazzled you should have to suck your
bedazzled we've come a long way yeah we
really have you want to see heather
graham just follow her you don't need to
freeze frame it on the boob that you see
in all heather graham films it's like
she has it in her writer graham is in
her name yes it's telling you not to
watch your movies absolutely go to
instagram okay insta heather graham now
let's move on to hunter biden's laptop
all right well look i know this seems
like remedial for some of you
but it's not it shouldn't be because you
know the story's true i know the hunter
biden laptop story is true because we
had well we had mayor giuliani on the
show and he showed the laptop for the
very first time on the show he's like
you mean this this just lapped up right
here i'm like that's a laptop like he
looked at a computer repair shop that's
i i have it right here i'm like don't
show that and then the next day he was
raided by the feds and they didn't take
the laptop and take the laptop
everything else they took everything
else they took his humidor they took
everything that wasn't child porn yeah
right he's holding the laptop up said
take this please investigate i don't
want to look at his laptop it's like
staring into a mirror isn't it
fbi so the new york times reported last
friday that in fact
hunter biden's laptop
the bad one the one that we know about
there's three i'll get to that in a
second that it was real oh all the news
that's fit to prince
just a little too late here's the thing
it actually wasn't mentioned in the
article at the new york times until
paragraph 24 oh wow 24 it needs to be in
the title and the entirety of the
article we screwed up you trusted us it
was real the end so that's below the
fold you're saying it's below the it
would be after the mad folding and
that's the end of the magazine oh that's
odd did you think this would have
affected the election maybe in any way i
got some numbers for you so
don't let them hit you in the teeth
here's what it says paragraph 24. those
emails were obtained by the new york
times from a cache of files that appear
to have come from a laptop abandoned by
mr biden in a delaware repair shop and i
know you guys are all saying yeah yeah
we know no the point is most of the
country did not know right you know
most of the country didn't know
certainly not the new york times readers
the email and others in the cache were
authenticated by people familiar with
them and with the investigation you mean
you at your cocktail party with the
bidens you found it's like hey uh
was there anything to that uh laptop
with all the kitty porn and crack yeah
that was me uh yeah better i better do
an addendum here okay thanks was it
hunter biden's like everybody said it
was yeah yeah yeah yeah so here's the
thing wow this is there are three
laptops
right so we left one at a repair shop
one was seized by the feds so that's two
and then we just found out there's a
third one
that it may or may not have been stolen
by russian drug dealers because he was
taping himself having sex with a russian
woman
who i'm sure was
just into him personally oh yeah yeah
liked him for him and they were going to
use their they may or may not be using
it for blackmail so this is hunter biden
going uh maybe i should get out ahead of
this one uh this is his lawyers i
guarantee you're going all right look
hunter
hunter okay you have this laptop all
right new york times just confirmed it
there was the other laptop seized by the
feds
we are doing our best to defend you big
guy is there anything else that you are
not telling me
no
no there's nothing else
what was that what was that
it seemed like a
like there might be about the house in
malibu and all the escorts there's one
is there any more homemade porn than we
already know one more
where i was using the webcam to film
myself engaging in intercourse with a
russian prostitute and the russian drug
dealers may or may not be using it to
blackmail me okay hunter this is
information that would have been useful
to me yesterday
what is their new strategy to flood the
market with 100 laptops is like oh we
hear a story about a laptop every week
now just desensitize them to hunter
biden child pornography god he's an
idiot so remember um this was uh of
course the media actually you know what
before before this before we play clip b
can i play clip one remember
former vice president joe biden i want
to sort of run the run through this with
you have the white house you have the
fbi you have the media you have big tech
but first let's go to former vice
president joe biden when he was asked
about the hunter biden scandals and it
gets better than the initial
part of the clip as much as
you don't want it to happen you know
that the people who want to make hay
in washington are going to try to use
your adult son as a cudgel against you
how do you feel about that and what do
you have to say to those people well
look uh
i have we have great confidence in our
son
why i'm not concerned about any
accusations but made against him
it's used to get to me
i think it's kind of foul play but look
it is what it is and he just bought him
new team he's a grown man he is the
smartest man i know i mean afraid of
pure intellectual capacity
um and uh and as long as he's good we're
good well he's not good as a father i
understand that and and and i
i admire that well you shouldn't he's
the smartest man you've known three
laptops how about you just give how
about he's smart enough to stop buying
laptops
just to install an app find my crack top
he can at least get one or two one of
the three back
well look in all fairness joe biden has
spent the last you know 700 years in
politics and there aren't that many
bright people apparently in politics so
it is the smartest person he knows there
are fewer bright people in politics than
there are child pornographers
there are fewer bright people in
politics and there are child
pornographers who lose three laptops
lose well usually when the fbi takes the
laptop they also take the guy who owns
it right especially considering that
he's the videographer
he was a cinematographer he wasn't just
engaging in sex with a minor he was
fellini in it
is that a dutch angle look at what yeah
this is
the lighting is spectacular it
absolutely is i feel i felt like i was
watching chinatown that was amazing
we're not worried about it we think it's
foul play do you understand the
liability first off not only of of this
being his son and we act like he's a kid
he's a grown ass man he's a man with
hair plugs his son i'm not talking about
former vice president biden in his 50s
and he was cutting business deals with
his father internationally do you have
any idea the kind of leverage that they
would have on him for crying out loud
people had uh hoover by the balls
because he dressed up like a woman every
now and then
he was making millions from a company
that he was the ceo of while just living
in malibu doing crack yes and drywall
seriously the best job ever
this is gypsum we can make that into
drugs so i want to rewind back in time
because this was prior this would have
been the now you know october surprises
if democrats
drop them it'll be everywhere if a true
october surprise drops from
conservatives republicans big tech and
media will just block it out and now you
know we don't need to talk about russia
russia meddling in election we have big
tech meddling you don't even need to
talk about votes and absentee ballots or
i mean people who by the way have been
indicted for vote camp for ballot
tampering or uh pallets of votes showing
up in detroit at 3 30 a.m and red flyer
wagons it's okay it's fine before we get
to any of that just a cooler burying a
significant story which happened from
the president the entire government our
intelligence officials
the fbi
oh big tech removing that's enough to
have changed this election that's all
you need it's enough so in case you've
forgotten
you remember that media
did not want to report on the story when
it broke prior to the election and of
course tried to dismiss it as what
something
russian disinformation which was the
actual lie for all we know these emails
are made up or maybe some are real and
others are fakes we don't know
that's right we do know that this is a
classic example of the right wing media
machine a tip from bannon and a hard
drive dump from rudy led a former
producer for sean hannity show to write
a story for the new york post that gets
splashed on the front page that rudy
then used to trash the bidens all over
fox and they're doing it almost every
hour of the day and trump has been
hyping the drama for days on end and
this is how it goes on and on now let's
pull up don jr's tweet from just a
little while ago how he says how will
the media attempt to sweep this one
under the rug
that is the meta narrative that's the
big story they're telling all about
grievance and bias and victimhood and
you think it's the biggest issue to
campaign on i think it's this i think
it's one of the biggest scandals i've
ever seen and you don't cover it
you want to talk about it well because
it can't be verified you want to talk
about insignificant things
i just didn't want to
he's gone into hiding
for five days he's gone into hiding he's
preparing for your delay oh it's taking
them five days
and this is what they do right brian
still to go we just don't know no you
don't want to know it can't be verified
you haven't even attempted to verify it
yeah you have not even attempted to
verify it just like with project veritas
just like when we here infiltrated
antifa and someone got arrested with the
weapon that they handed to my producer
that day
they had no interest in verifying it
whatsoever nor did the fbi who we later
found out one of the members of the fbi
who we were working with as it related
to infiltrating antifa part of the sting
who plotted the whitmer murder yeah i
found that one out they were trying to
honeypot us and it didn't work because
it turns out that we're just decent
people here so they moved on down the
trail my point is this the media says we
don't know well you can know we didn't
verify how about you verified it's like
when elon omar married her brother like
well we couldn't verify it so it's not
not true okay it's your job verify it
right and brian stelter there you could
very very clearly see fourth gen he was
doing yes all he was doing was carrying
water for the biden administration or
the previous you know
trying to get elected to become the
administration yeah he was basically
just carrying water for the guy and it
was so obvious to us at the time if you
want to cover that story and you don't
know that it's real you can say
big if true something along those lines
and say this is breaking we cannot
control do you mean like they did for a
very very long time on russia and this
is big if true turns out it wasn't true
which is what brings us to the next
point are institutions they want to
claim that we're sowing distrust well
i'm not sowing distrust so much as i am
you shouldn't trust them 50 former
intelligence officials signed a letter
calling the emails yeah
right calling some of the information on
these laptops russian disinformation
which we know is verifiably false as you
now know i'm not saying it the new york
times is saying so they had to sign a
petition to change a narrative yes
pretty much wow they say we're we're
intelligence officials so you know you
can trust us well now that i'm not
saying this the new york times is saying
that obviously the story is confirmed so
those officials are they going to be
brought up on charges
somebody should are they is anyone going
to face any first off they should face
charges for election meddling they
should face charges uh for
at least being i don't know if you can
be an accessory but anyone who didn't
verify or had access to this laptop
child pornography
just to be clear i don't think there's a
charge for incestuous pornography but
there should be because it's gross and
if you do that elon omar loses office my
point here is
this has been going on for a long time
and they don't vary so what happened
before the election right before the
election facebook limited the spread of
the new york post story okay you know
that twitter flat out locked the new
york post out of its account they banned
the post and they blocked users from
sharing the article so this is the only
takeaway that you need
it's enough for an unfairly freest and
safest election in history best yes
there were there were polls going around
that if people had known about this
story if people had known about this
scandal there was a poll that showed 9.4
percent of swing state voters would have
changed their votes if things 9.4
doesn't sound like a lot but in swing
states that's enough that means that
trump donald trump would have won
pennsylvania
michigan did wisconsin
georgia arizona nevada
would have been a wipeout
and think about this for a second the
consequences of again let's set up we're
going to have the allies and the axis
the access okay who do we have we have
former vice president biden and his
screw-up son
we have nancy pelosi we have everyone in
the dnc okay so hold dnc let's put them
there then we have the media legacy
media abc n a uh cbs msnbc all of them
everyone not named fox news
all of print outside of new york post
then who else we have we have the fbi we
have intelligence officials fbi uh cia
do cia doj
then who else we have we have the most
powerful companies that have ever
existed in google youtube
facebook twitter all of them decided
you're not going to know about this
story because we can't verify it no one
in this chain of command said hey you
know what let's verify this is true
because we are on laptop number three
so rather than russian meddling which is
what the intelligence officials tried to
sell you we now know that if this had
not been throttled by big tech and their
lackeys in media and government we would
not only have president trump think
about what are the consequences we very
likely wouldn't have sky high inflation
we very likely wouldn't have the russia
ukraine conflict we very like we
absolutely wouldn't have had the
afghanistan withdrawal and we likely
would have had a bounce back economy
without you being perpetually locked
down
that's all because of tech
media censorship who by the way are
being directed by this government you
just saw saki calling for them
all because of tech censorship of one
key
story that just changed the course of
this country forever
think about that for a second the next
time they're trying to tell you oh huh
this isn't john hannity just shut up
just shut up please for crying out
notice they always [ __ ] about one
network it's like yeah but what about
all of the other ones yeah you know how
they never covered twitter blocking it
and then not letting them repost not
letting them keep that original post i'm
sorry when they came back and said you
know we we actually made a mistake a
mistake are bad right are bad now they
can't it's like well they can just
repost the article what about the
millions of people potentially that had
seen that certainly hundreds of
thousands at the time that it got no
many many many you don't get millions
back you don't get those back you don't
get those views back let alone how the
algorithm favors it you have to pause
and then just say oops we're sorry right
that's it and then at that point by the
way the media just covers and twitter
had to ban it because it's not a true
story and then months later well over a
year later after the election new york
times like oh you know actually it turns
out it was true hold on hold on a second
because your paper should be burned to
the ground if that's the case
somebody the problem is they knew it was
true at the time of course that's what
bothers me the most about it yes and the
lack of respect yes
mostly
well this sex yes the the sex that
hunter had with
those maybe or maybe not his knees yes
that hurt the most yeah where's the
second most of the lack of respect not
that it was particularly respectful and
the third was that they knew yes the
third was that they knew the point is
it's malt as oprah which it's
multi-layered it's like her book club
she likes books that are multi-layered
because she's like multi-layered
[Laughter]
um and by the way we actually i really
quickly before we move on to the
ukrainian refugee crisis we actually
tried opening a crowder shop in a
gentrified quarter black uh neighborhood
and it did not
what did not go
what's well would that be all
no actually man i was checking out that
shirt and i want to get one for myself
do you have one of those around here
no
it's available at protoshop.com it's
this hateful racist show i watch
so you're
racist i watch it ironically everybody
who watches the show is racist everybody
who is on the show is racist you're
racist i'm racist
and you don't have that here no at this
at the store no it's racist ironically
store crowdershop.com
[Music]
head over to the shop support the fight
and buy some cool threads it's the tits
pajamas
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
i'm a child i'm
sorry that hurts so much
i can well hurt that person something
yeah that's not me yeah that's your twin
yeah it's my triplet it's your twin
brother i just realized we're actually
going over time and i have to go
change my mind that will be coming out
hey by the way just so you know hint for
the change in my mind that's going to be
happening it's going to be at uh can i
say it's going to be a
it's
going to be a school a school
usually a lot of times we'll realize 50
percent of the change hormones are just
in a street corner yeah
unt and then we're going to be hey i
don't think that biological uh male
should be allowed to compete in uh
women's sports so i expect the reaction
for many people to be this
and i'm like hey
it should be uh
yep yep it's gonna be a lot of fun so
we're over time i have to go uh get
ready for this and uh the ukrainian
refugee crisis story is one that i want
just let me just give you a quick let me
give you a brief run and we'll talk
about it tomorrow the media wants you to
think that uh you know we only care
about refugees from ukraine because
they're white it's not true we accept
more non-white refugees poland by the
way accepted more ukrainian refugees
than any country in the world right now
and they've been excoriated for not
doing enough and the real issue here is
that of course americans want to support
uh women and children who are fleeing a
country at war as opposed to
military-aged
men uh who are fleeing non-persecution
because they're muslim in the middle
east and it's been going on since first
so we're going to talk about it tomorrow
the point is this don't let anyone make
you think that you're racist if you look
at ukrainian refugees as less of a
problem than say uh isis defectors
yeah that sounds right well we still
have a whole segment we'll do it
tomorrow uh i'm going to we're going to
go to my club right now and by the way i
didn't say smash that like button you
need to you guys need to smash the like
button
especially if you want you know smash
the like button if you want more change
my mind because it's pretty tough for us
to do now with security you know i got
that acid milkshake i looked like katie
home for a bit so
it's amazing what they can do with tear
duct surgery
smash the like button youtube piss off
[Music]
[Music]